I think everyone has an origin
story that matters and
that's important.
[MUSIC]
>> I had always known I wanted to
go to business school since I
was probably seven years.
>> I always knew I wanted to start
my own company,
the question was what?
>> Our mission is to stop
climate change.
>> Build an impact oriented company
that made healthcare better.
>> Changing the plastics industry.
>> Advancing health equity by
making mental health care radically
accessible and inclusive.
>> To improve a billion lives by
scaling innovations that would
change the world.
>> I was all in.
>> When we are successful as
an industry we should
put the human at the center.
>> By being part of an ecosystem of
change makers who believe the world
can be changed.
>> There is no single path.
>> That human impulse to
make things better.
>> We have to radically
challenge the status quo with love,
compassion, and
the willingness to sacrifice some
of the opportunities for
the betterment of the collective.
That is what it means to be
a servant leader and that is what
we were taught at Stanford.